are you gorgeous you're gorgeous well
first of all we're going to ask you
about this project but where the heck do
you keep your oscar because that's what
i want to know um you know it's on um
it's on my mantel at home in new york
i i mean it's kind of awkward you know
you wake up in the morning you walk by
and you're like that's there yeah but i
don't know it was such a special thing
to have happen i think eventually maybe
i'll put it somewhere else but for now
i'm really proud of it yeah and it just
reminds me to keep going and that i can
do hard things and
that good things can happen you know
like extraordinary like shouldn't happen
things could happen so don't give up on
yourself no no they they were meant to
happen this project is so special
another special thing for you what does
this one mean
this is immensely special because i will
tell you something um
west side story was given to the world
in december and this is the first call
that i got it was around christmas time
and they offered me the job
so this is the first job that i was
offered post-westside premiere and i was
not any sort of an award winner and i
grew up watching all the disney films so
it means the world to me to continue my
relationship with the disney family
and to be given the challenge and the
task of
bringing a new character to the world a
character that looks like me
that you know has a background that is
mixed you know that that really can
reflect these values that we've been
talking about in so many different ways
for a long time that means a lot to me i
take it very seriously and i'm really
stoked to be working with an incredible
team that includes chris buckley and
vaughn and and julie michaels writing
the music like we're
we come from so many different walks of
life and i think what we're making is
special and i'm excited people to see it
i'm sorry that was a long answer oh it
was perfect well i am so happy for you
congratulations
you